we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p any time that
the fancy should strike i don't know if
that makes any sense I like it any time
that the mood should strike you can call
2192 david p and leave us voicemail here
is a voicemail we received hi David this
is Lizzie in Los Angeles I'm poor I
don't have a lot of money but I am a
subscriber but since this crisis with
youtube I have joined patreon and give
you an extra two dollars a month and
I've just ordered something from Amazon
through your link in addition i have
bookmarked that Lincoln from now on when
I shop on amazon I will use that link so
i hope these extra measures will help
and i hope that everybody else will do
the thing because i think it will really
make a huge difference for you and you
have to stay on because your show is
fantastic well thank you thank Patrick
and thank everybody who is involved with
it all best wishes bye bye thank you and
it's not even i heard that we need
everybody to do it if only five percent
of our audience donated two bucks a
month at patreon.com slash david pakman
show the youtube crisis is over i would
be ready to declare it over the way Sean
Spicer tried to declare over the Trump
Russia scandal even though he was wrong
I would be able to if five percent of
our audience went to patreon.com/scishow
bed Pakman show right now and said I'm
going to pledge two bucks a month
twenty-four dollars per year I would
declare right here with peace and love
Pat the entire YouTube crisis over right
because this is really inhibiting our
ability to grow as a show and getting
more people to donate on patreon and
sign up for memberships that would be
able to undo what you to buzz on to
every single person who does it undoes
the damage done by the YouTube ad
boycott we will talk about a lot of
really great stuff on the bonus show
today I'm out of time but what I will
tell you instead of telling you
everything that's on the bonus show is
that it's really great and you should
sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership to get instant access